bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
cette semaine de sa verrière ogec
bonjour ya dans l'actualité politique et
parlementaire cette semaine il ya eu
d'abord comme une ambiance de gueule de
bois du côté de l'ump après un meeting
du bourget et surtout après les propos
de nicolas sarkozy évoquant l'hypothèse
d'une défaite
le moral est bon clament les
parlementaires réunis au qg du parti
la méthode coué a rien de tel et puis
dans la lancée du bourget françois
hollande a détaillé ses 60 propositions
pour la présidentielle 20 milliards
d'euros de mesures nouvelles qui seront
compensés par une réduction des niches
fiscales programme flou et irréaliste
estime la majorité
enfin le sénat a définitivement adopté
le texte pénalisant la négation des
génocides dont le génocide arménien le
sénat en état de siège avec aux
alentours des manifestations
turco-arménienne un sénat divisée sur ce
texte et qui a toutefois fini par le
goûter est avec nous pour commenter
cette actualité alain joyandet bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député ump de haute
saône depuis 2002 vous avez été
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
coopération et la francophonie dans le
gouvernement de françois fillon 2 vous
avez dû en partir pour une histoire de
jet privé utilisé pour un déplacement
martinez que vous avez depuis réintégré
les bancs de l'assemblée
quels sont aujourd'hui vos relations
avec à nicolas sarkozy excellente le
président m'a confié une mission
il ya quelques mois sur l'emploi des
jeunes j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
remettre mon rapport aux appareils dans
cette émission de long prologue et voilà
aucun problème voilà donc maintenant
parler de l'actualité de la semaine avec
lundi le sénat qui connaît une journée
très mouvementée
un final en état de siège pour l'examen
du texte sur la négation des génocides
un texte finalement voté dans la soirée
et à l'extérieur du sénat manifestants
pro turc et pro arméniens s'affrontent
regardez ce reportage d'alexandra
colinot à droite la délégation
arménienne à gauche la délégation turque
entre les deux quelques fauteuils pour
les séparer et pas un regard
depuis la tribune présidentielle chacun
écoute les débats l'ambassadeur turc est
particulièrement attentif lorsque
l'assemblée a voté la loi le 22 décembre
dernier il avait été rappelé en turquie
pour quelques semaines
si la loi passe cet après midi la
riposte d'ankara sera immédiate parce
que la turquie ne pourrait jamais
accepter ça dont il faut il faut que le
chrono + française ça ça pour aller
jamais elles vont en libye si ça passe
malheureusement on va continuer à le
définir
alors là on ne peut pas dire que ça bon
l'étude des relations entre la tuque et
les phrases nous justement parce de caen
dans l'hémicycle de caen aussi dans la
rue des drapeaux turcs et des cartes
d'électeur en guise de banderoles d'un
côté des drapeaux français et des photos
du génocide arménien de l'autre entre
les deux un no man's land et quelques
crs pour les défenseurs turcs que la loi
est électoraliste
alors ils sont venus rappeler aux
politiques que leur voix aussi
compteront pour les élections
présidentielles et où franco turc on est
aussi là pour
en tant que c'est en france et électeurs
pour les élections présidentielles des
citoyens français aussi dans le camp
arméniens venus eux soutenir une loi
qu'ils jugent protectrice pour leur
histoire le rôle du parlement c'est de
protéger les citoyens lorsqu'on leur dit
votre histoire n'a pas eu lieu
vous êtes des menteurs et on est libre
de vos insultes et en turquie et en
arménie les peuples suivre les débats à
la télévision
des dizaines d'envoyés spéciaux des deux
camps sont venus couvrir l'événement
alors joyandet c'est un sujet brûlant
qui a créé la polémique et de fortes
réactions en turquie
au final est ce que cette loi était
vraiment nécessaire
je crois que le fait de punir la
négation des génocides la pole beaucoup
de génocide
trois ou quatre je pense que sur le fond
on peut être que d'accord
après il ya la question de l'opportunité
ou pas de ce moment du parlement
français à titre personnel je n'ai pas
participé au vote c'est pas un désaccord
de fourme j'ai quelques doutes justement
sur l'opportunité de ce texte la
question mémorielle est ce que c'est le
parlement français qui doit se saisir en
ce moment de ces grands sujets voilà
donc révisé au sein même du gouvernement
alain juppé par exemple ou bruno le
maire se sont prononcés contre
ainsi pas prononcés contre enfin je vois
là j'étais pas je n'étais pas convaincu
que c'était le moment en tout cas sur le
fond c'est incontestable je crois que
c'est c'est normal qu'un pays comme la
france qui comme le berceau des droits
de l'homme et ce genre d'attitude mais
le parlement français a beaucoup
d'urgences en ce moment et nos
concitoyens sont plus officielle n'était
pas une urgence ce sujet un côté
électoraliste là dedans non je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire qui à côté victoria
parce que vous savez y ait autant de
coups à prendre que de bénéfices
l'état français souverains le parlement
a le droit de délibérer après chaque
parlementaire en son âme et conscience
je veux pas rajouter la polémique à la
polémique donc joué j'ai une attitude
plutôt réservé et jean voilà je vais pas
non plus être et sur les conséquences
avec la turquie nos relations avec
ankara
est-ce que ça va se tasser on sait que
nicolas sarkozy a adressé une lettre je
pense que la réaction à chaud est normal
de la part des turcs mais je sais je
connais bien la diplomatie française je
fais confiance à nos diplomates
bien sûr nicolas sarkozy pour que après
cette séquence un peu difficiles les
relations entre la france et la turquie
soit apaisée un mot sur l'aspect
économique les mesures de rétorsion
économique est ce qu'on peut les
craindre et allemand c'est à cela que je
pense quand je parle des relations
apaisées
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises
européennes ont des relations très très
importante avec avec la turquie alors
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas laisser non
plus les grands sujets de société à la
remorque des échanges économiques mais
enfin c'est un tout et dans les jours
qui viennent encore une fois je fais
confiance à la diplomatie française pour
pour arranger les choses mais là
pourquoi selon vous l'at-on fait à ce
moment là c'était vraiment pas opportun
à côté on peut pas arrêter de tout on
peut pas tout arrêter à quelques mois
d'une élection vous savez qu'on est
passé du septennat au quinquennat
donc est-ce qu'il faut se dire que six
mois avant les élections il faut tout
arrêter et plus de délibération il ya
plus de décisions vous verrez que dans
les jours qui viennent il ya aussi des
décisions compliquées apprendre que
celle ci n'était pas une urgence alors
on l'aura compris je rappelle aussi que
c'était une initiative parlementaire
interrogé par un sénat de droite à
l'époque la nuit mais c'est quand même
une initiative parlementaire sondés ce
sont des des députés qui ont porté cette
cette idée devant le parlement
le président de la république a redonné
au parlement au début du quinquennat
beaucoup d'initiatives contrairement
d'ailleurs à ce que l'on peut entendre
ici ou là c'est une initiative
parlementaire
un certain nombre de parlementaires
ensuivie d'autre part et voilà c'est ça
la démocratie
allez alain dujon les voir on va
poursuivre est que le mardi
l'ump qui digère lentement le meeting du
bourget tout le monde en convient même à
droite françois hollande a réalisé un
sans faute dimanche lors de son grand
show du bourget alors on ce mardi les
parlementaires ump viennent resserrer
les rangs lors d'un déjeuner au nouveau
siège du parti
mot d'ordre sourire notamment devant la
caméra de marion lefebvre remobilisation
générale au siège de l'ump
ministres et parlementaires affichent
leur unité fini le blues post meeting
socialiste séquence méthode coué comment
va le moral très bien fiction pour le
moral soit mauvais mon moral est parfait
et je peux te tiens à vous dire qu'on
m'a percé à la loyale c'est à dire avec
franc et cordial quelle stratégie est la
meilleure et c'est pour ça qu'on est
assez serein même si ce n'est pas facile
interport d'un petit peu de sang-froid
dans le sens pas céder à l'agitation
générale
l'ump organise la riposte plus question
d' attaques personnelles contre françois
hollande à la consigne c'est désormais
de pointer les contradictions et le
financement du programme socialiste mais
surtout de vanter le bilan du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
les mois de janvier dans les campagnes
présidentielles on les connaît bien
c'est toujours les mêmes il ya les
vedettes du mois de janvier les héros du
mois de janvier
les battus du mois de janvier mais
l'élection est en mai et d'ici là il va
se passer beaucoup beaucoup de choses
derrière l'image le discours officiel
pointe le malaise de certains députés
le candidat nicolas sarkozy ne fait plus
rêver la droite populaire la
personnalité ne jouais pas d'une
adhésion à total du peuple français
c'est également une réalité
ça va pas être un choix enthousiaste
avec un choix de réalisme et de
rationalisme l'offensive de l'ump est en
marche mais sans le candidat nicolas
sarkozy ne semble pas vouloir accélérer
son calendrier
alors c'est un peu la soupe à la grimace
cette semaine on sent tout le monde un
peu crispé aux mêmes aussi écouter ce
que j'ai l'air crispé
j'ai assisté aux propos de mes collègues
de l'ump je me demandais où fossiles et
l ump où je pense que le moment le
moment est à la mobilisation
et je crois vraiment qu'il faut parler
du fond de l' on dit le succès du
meeting de monsieur hollande
heureusement que monsieur hollande peut
organiser un meeting il est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir le fond qu'est
ce qu'ils proposent un mot alain
joyandet
l'image est importante surtout dans
cette période y at il pas un problème de
communication alors que françois
hollande triomphons bourgeat de voir
nicolas sarkozy naviguer sur une pirogue
et puis évoqué l'hypothèse de sa défaite
nicolas sarkozy est un être humain comme
tout le monde et vous savez quelle est
sa liberté de ton y compris devant les
journalistes qu'il a eu cette réflexion
après tout pourquoi pas parce que vous
êtes sentis abandonnés çà vous êtes où
mais enfin écoutez entre le président de
la république qui éventuellement
s'interroge sur son avenir
les voir françois hollande qui nous
explique qui a pas besoin d'élections
puisqu'il est déjà élu il est déjà en
négociation avec madame merkel son
avenir candidats qui sont parti en fusée
je pense que c'est au fond assez sain
que que l'on dise
parfois quand même aussi ce qui peut ce
qui peut être dans notre dans notre for
intérieur avec une stratégie je ne pense
pas que ce soit ne se reconnaît
déclaration candidature se fait attendre
je pense pas que ce soit une stratégie
je pense que il ya un moment donné
pourquoi pas une élection présidentielle
et des phases qui se succèdent qui sont
pas toutes les mêmes
le fait que président et disent là-bas
après tout pour qu'on dit qu'il ne
commet comment dire on dit qu'il est
parfois pas assez humain et bien au
moins voilà une preuve de dédain réflexe
très très humain qui montre comment
fragile avant avoir une élection
présidentielle vous savez je coupais 1%
je pense que le président n'est pas
forcément celui que l'on que l'on
caricature il a aussi des réactions et
ce qui me choque beaucoup plus c'est la
posture de monsieur hollande a écouté
c'est caricatural il a gagné les
élections sont faites ce que nous avons
fait pendant cinq ans il n'y a rien de
bon on a encore vu très très récemment
danser dans ses déclarations il ne
reconnaît pas le moindre le moindre
mérite au travail que nous avons fait en
cinq ans c'est de ça dont ce que vous
lui laissez totalement le champ libre
pour l'instant oui mais je pense que je
pense qu'il ya un temps pour tout encore
une fois c'est le quinquennat c'est quoi
le temps pour nicolas vient le temps
pour nicolas sarkozy en ce moment c'est
le temps du travail
on a quand même des sujets importants
vous avez vu ce qui se passe au niveau
de l'emploi
il ya des mesures très urgentes qui ont
été prises prises pour l'emploi le 18
janvier qui sont d'ores et déjà en
application
on en aura peut-être tout à l'heure
imaginez que le président des arbitres
soient déjà candidats qui est-ce qui
préside la france dans les mois qui
viennent alors qu'il ya des décisions
très importantes à prendre moi je suis
tout à fait sur la ligne du du
calendrier tel qu'il est défini
travaillons le plus longtemps possible
candidature début mars c'est le
président qui fera son calendrier en
réclame une déclaration beaucoup plus
tôt
oui mais enfin je pense que le freesia
par étiez le président préside
on a besoin de travailler je pense que
les français sont pas encore
complètement dans la campagne
foncez ils attendent que l'on règle un
certain nombre de en tout cas qu'on se
battre contre un certain nombre de
phénomènes comme l'explosion éventuelle
du chômage si nous ne faisons rien on
voit que le chômage a beaucoup plus
exposés dans d'autres pays que européens
par rapport à ce qui se passait en
france même si la situation est
difficile
les mesures qui sont prises sont bonnes
parlons-en l'emploi des jeunes le
chômage partiel les entreprises ou
encore peut-être avant de poursuivre on
vous a vu réagir ce christian vanneste
qui fait donc partie de la droite
populaire la droite populaire qui en ce
moment se détache beaucoup dans ses
propos de nicolas sarkozy président et
surtout candidats éventuels candidats
est ce qu'elle vous fait peur cette
droite populaire qui risque de lâcher
le président l'union pour un mouvement
populaire est riche de ses différences
chacun sa sensibilité
bon moi je suppose que vous regardiez le
sujet vous aviez l'air plus plus énervé
que consentants non mais je pense qu'au
mans devrait être plus on a besoin d'eux
de réhabiliter absolument le bilan du
président qui est excellent et le bilan
de la majorité
bien sûr les chiffres du chômage sont là
mais bien sûr il ya eu des crises du
français comprennent ça donc je pense
qu'il faut réhabiliter le bilan du
président il faut faire campagne il faut
être solidaire faut être fier de ce que
nous avons fait ce que propose monsieur
hollande c'est l'antithèse l'antithèse
de ce dont la france a besoin j'espère
qu'on aurait autant dire de s'expliquer
là dessus donc voilà solidarité
enthousiasme une campagne six mois parce
qu'au mois de janvier c'est la séquence
hollande très bien des tout seul comme
candidat heureusement faut bien qu'il
faut bien le dire collègues parier de ce
que fait monsieur hollande c'est tout à
fait normal
juste un mot sur la question vous vous
posiez sur le le
évidemment le meeting réussi je vais pas
contester le fait que meeting était
réussi de la même manière que je vois
bien que monsieur hollande comme on dit
dans le milieu médiatique est plutôt bon
dans l'exercice
dans la forme mais parlons du fond et
c'est ça notre travail à nous élus de la
majorité de montrer ce qui ce qui ne va
pas dans le programme de l'us yolande on
va y venir justement alors à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le gouvernement qui
cette fois monte au créneau
il s'en prend à la gauche et au
programme de françois hollande un
échange musclé avec jean marc ayrault
julie de crack selon résidents djakolaj
chez calmann-lévy peu ambiance
électrique cet après midi pour un
règlement de comptes en règle entre la
gauche et la droite et c'est la majorité
qui a ouvert les hostilités contre une
cible françois hollande quand vous
parlez emploi et pouvoir d'achat c'est
un oral de rattrapage de votre part
parce que dimanche au bourget il n'a pas
été question d'emploi il n'a pas été
question de pouvoir d'achat
vos priorités à vous dimanche c'est la
nomination du président de france
télévisions les français apprécieront
quand certains
fond de la finance l'ennemi absolu nous
c'est le chômage
notre ennemi absolu face aux attaques de
l'ump contre françois hollande le patron
des députés socialistes prend la parole
pour une intervention non préparé le
discours de françois hollande dimanche
dernier a été un succès parce qu' ils
s'aiment un tel vent de panique à l'ump
que vous en êtes réduits à la caricature
et à transformer cette séance des
questions au gouvernement
non pas en question au ministre en
exercice
mais en séance de démolition de
caricatures monsieur ayrault votre
conception du débat politique
c'est oui vous avez le droit de
critiquer toutes les actions du
gouvernement
mais le gouvernement et la majorité eux
n'ont pas le droit de dire que le
candidat socialiste a fait un discours
dimanche qui est un discours d'illusions
alors dans l'hémicycle 1 ce mardi on a
eu quand même cette impression que la
majorité était dans l'opposition
c'est un peu ça les questions
d'actualité servent pour les uns et pour
les autres s'exprimer je pense que
effectivement les ministres ont le droit
et ont même le devoir donc dans la
réponse qu'ils font de m quand même en
perspective les réponses qui sont
apportées par les uns et par les autres
sur la question de l'emploi la droite à
la défensive quand même depuis quelques
jours sur la défensive non mais on va
pas nier
enfin je ne vais pas nier qu'il ya
actuellement une séquence hollande il ya
un moment hollande comme il y aura
d'autres moments
nous n'avons pas de candidat donc et je
ne le regrette pas parce qu'encore une
fois le tempo me semble-t-il est bon jeu
rendre hommage d'ailleurs un xavier
bertrand qui sur cette question de
l'emploi fait un travail absolument
remarquable et qui mobilise toutes les
énergies
il est bien normal que dans sa réponse
il pointe du doigt ce que propose
monsieur hollande qui va d'ailleurs
al'inverse de ce nous aurons besoin
pendant toujours la même chose sans
candidat ump sans programme ump et bien
le sujet de conversation c'est françois
hollande
donc c'est quand même une période
difficile pour vous vous savez ça trop
de retard justement
écoutez regardant ce que prend françois
hollande la tante de l'accord de la
déclaration de candidature de nicolas
sarkozy c'est coutu vous même un réglage
secret vous même les journalistes et
observateurs vous semblez d'ailleurs
exprimé une certaine attente une
certaine impatience de voir notre
candidat donc dès que notre candidat
sera auprès de vous je pense que du coup
vous allez pouvoir vraiment on parlait
beaucoup et durera donc la séquence
futur pour notre candidat et pourquoi
cette impression quand même que la
droite a du mal à trouver des angles
d'attaqué
je pense que je pense que médiatiquement
on est dans cette séquence et les
commentaires sont sur la forme et par et
pas sur le fond je pense donc il faut
vraiment aller dans le fond des choses
sur notre bilan sur ce que nous avons
fait sur ce que propose françois l'enjeu
parents est ce que françois hollande ne
vous rappelle pas un peu le candidat
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 c'est à dire
celui qui surprend celui qui propose des
choses différentes
celui qui dicte les thèmes de campagne
non parce que ce que proposait nicolas
sarkozy correspondait aux besoins de
notre pays
cette époque alors que ce que propose
françois hollande ne correspond pas un
exemple il nous annonce 150 mille
emplois pour les jeunes dans la fonction
publique
si vous y ajoutez les 60000 postes
d'enseignants ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'il faut alléger
la dépense publique tout le monde est
d'accord tous les pays qui réussissent
le fond et qu'il faut libérer les
énergies libérer les entreprises le
programme de monsieur lancé je matraque
les entreprises et les travailleurs et
je jalouse redit la dépense publique
c'est exactement l'inversé de ce dont
nous avons besoin les 9 millions de
travailleurs de salariés qui apprennent
que monsieur hollande va supprimer la
défiscalisation de charges sur les
heures supplémentaires
comment vont ils réagir dans ma vie j'ai
quatre mille salariés peugeot au moment
des 35 heures un grand nombre d'entre
eux ne pouvait même plus rembourser les
traites de leur maison
on a libéré les 35 heures on a redonné
le droit aux heures supplémentaires
on a défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires c'était travailler plus
pour gagner plus et c'est toujours
travailler plus pour gagner plus
monsieur hollande nous dit si c'est moi
on enlève tout ça donc le travailler
plus pour gagner plus c'est fini on voit
des jeunes à nouveau dans le secteur
public ont chargé la barque et on prend
30 milliards et on prend 30 milliards
d'impôts en plus aux français c'est
exactement
l' inverse de ce qu il faut pour la
france et celle inverse de ce que font
les pays qui réussissent à venir bien
sûr plus en longueur totale heures et
mardi a comme une bonne nouvelle pour
l'ump une dizaine de responsables du
nouveau centre dont les ministres
maurice leroy et françois sauvadet ont
publié une tribune dans laquelle ils
annoncent qu'ils soutiendront nicolas
sarkozy il abandonne donc le candidat de
leur parti hervé morin
une décision qu'ils expliquent par le
danger qu'il y aurait à un éparpillement
des voix au premier tour
donc je s'éviter le retour de la gauche
en france je crois qu'on a
nicolas sarkozy a montré sa capacité à
apporter des réponses concrètes dans le
temps de crise qu'on traverse et donc
voilà je souhaite aujourd'hui que chacun
prenne ses aises pas été bien vite
d'ailleurs tous les dirigeants du
nouveau centre tous les militants du
nouveau centre a partagé avec nous cette
ambition commune de sortir le pays de la
crise
- doigts pour cent mais c'est toujours
ça prix du côté des centristes
oui c'est pas les 1% c'est le sel
symbole c'est le symbole du
rassemblement je pense qu'effectivement
tous ceux qui souhaitent que l'action
engagée
continuons intérêt à se rassembler pour
notre pays
hervé prendra la décision qui sera la
sienne m'appartient pas de deux
comment dire d'insister se trouve sur le
sujet m enfin tout ce qu'il a dans le
sens du rassemblement autour du
président hervé morin était quand même
ministre un certain temps je pense que
s'il venait à prendre une décision et
que dans la foulée il appelle à voter
pour nicolas sarkozy si celui ci est
candidat au moment où il sera candidat
tout ça me paraît très très naturel été
reçue récemment à l'elysée
il aurait reçu l'assurance que s'il
serait terrain il n'y aurait pas de
candidat ump dans sa circonscription
face à lui ça vous semble ont écouté
je pense que c'est tout à fait normal
que si des accords politiques pour les
élections présidentielles il se décline
pour les élections légistatives il me
semble d'ailleurs que c'est ce que
françois hollande a fait avec les verts
je crois que les verts ont d'ores et
déjà six et éventuellement les
socialistes venaient à gagner une place
de choix dans les circonscriptions et au
parlement en contrepartie de quoi
deuxième tour j'imagine qu'ils vont
appeler à voter pour françois hollande
s'acquitta c'est normal c'est le
rassemblement chacun exprime sa
différence et puis un moment donné on se
rassemble dans celui qui va occuper tout
l'espace centriste c'est françois bayrou
crédité de 14 à 15% dans les sondages
c'est lui qui peut éliminer un candidat
ump au premier tour et est éliminé salut
je pense que au fond l'intelligence
collective des français qui ont
d'ailleurs pris en compte ce qui s'est
passé en 2002 rock leur intelligence
collective fera en sorte que au deuxième
tour il ya un vrai choix républicain
pour servir la démocratie est le vrai
choix républicain dans notre système
politique c'est quand même que les deux
candidats des deux principaux partis de
la majorité et de l'opposition
s'affrontent au deuxième tour je crois
que ce serait bon pour notre démocratie
aujourd'hui le candidat le plus
difficile à battre reprenez que la
sarkozye est ce que c'est françois
hollande ou est-ce que c'est très bien
je pense qu'il ya pas de candidat
plus difficile à battre les uns que les
autres je pense l'élection
présidentielle en fait ces deux
élections et un premier tour
voilà il faut il faut être dans les deux
premiers au premier tour et puis le
deuxième tour toutes les cartes sont
rebattues je vous rappelle que en 2007
aucun candidat éliminé au premier tour
n'a appelé à voter nicolas sarkozy au
deuxième tour
aucun et nicolas sarkozy avec les
français aujourd'hui sont libres de
leurs de leurs suffrages c'est pas parce
qu'on leur dit qu'il faut voter pour
untel ou untel qui sont comme sa
discipline et ils vont choisir au
premier tour et ils vont éliminer c'est
ça le sens
encore faut-il se qualifier pour le
premier pour le second tour bien sûr
c'est pour ça que 15 % français commence
à faire beaucoup quand même
oui c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut faire
campagne c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
présent c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir
un peu d'enthousiasmé que les périodes
creuses puisqu'on vous traverse est vrai
dans les sondages une période creuse
ça s'est toujours vu dans les élections
présidentielles rappelez-vous juste
novembre je crois 94
jacques chirac avait 14 ou 15 % dans les
sondages et sur un plateau de télévision
du service public une journaliste bien
connu lui disais mais monsieur chirac
finalement vous ne serez pas candidat et
quelques mois plus tard il était
président de la république donc gardons
nous de tout pronostic
il faut travailler jusqu'au bout en ce
qui nous concerne quand la campagne
viendra vous verrez quand je pense que
si nicolas sarkozy est candidat ce que
je souhaite est dans son calendrier est
ce que je souhaite aussi lorsqu'il se
mettra en campagne je pense que ce sera
une toute autre campagne ya un certain
nombre il ya un certain nombre de choses
que lui seul pourra expliquer les
français les vainqueurs du mois de
janvier n'étaient pas ceux du mois de
mer c'est la phrase tosic une semaine
alors on passe au mercredi avec
l'annoncé des derniers chiffres du
chômage
29 mille 700 chômeurs supplémentaires au
mois de décembre la progression a été
constante au cours de l'année et la
france n'est plus très loin de la barre
des trois millions de demandeurs
d'emploi mathilde derrière il y à un
mois il avait atteint son plus haut
niveau depuis 12 ans en décembre
ils sont 29 1700 personnes de plus sans
aucune activité
désormais la france compte plus de deux
millions huit cent mille demandeurs
d'emploi les personnes qui exercent une
activité réduite augmente elle aussi de
0,6 pour cent soit 25000 personnes
supplémentaires cela fait des mois que
le chômage augmente et contrairement à
ce qu'il avait promis aux français
nicolas sarkozy ne les protège pas au
contraire les politiques qu'ils mettent
en oeuvre aggravent les conséquences
d'une crise déjà redoutable mais qui est
pire encore en france car les politiques
qu'il conduit sont des politiques
économiques à contresens du côté de la
majorité où l'on avait annoncé avant
même les résultats de mauvais chiffres
on tente de minimiser c'est compliqué
mais vous savez encore une fois la
france n'est pas une île
au chômage en espagne c'est x 3 la
première puissance du monde et etats
unis le chômage chez x 2 voies là c'est
pas pour ça qu'il faut forcément dire
que en france c'est mieux il faut aussi
regarder ce qui existe ailleurs
en un an le chômage a progressé de 5,6
pour cent c'est deux fois plus qu'en
2010 un gros point noir à trois mois des
élections dans le bilan du président pas
encore candidat alain joyandet après le
sommet social nicolas sarkozy a repris
intégralement donc une mesure qui
étaient contenues dans le rapport que
vous lui avait rendu ça s'appelle le
contraste des recharges sont donc les
très petites entreprises moins de 10
salariés qui seront exonérés de charges
pendant un an
c'est sa cible six mois si elles
embauchent au smic des jeunes de moins
de 26 ans donc ça évidemment cela vous
réjouit quel impact en termes d'emplois
selon je pense que l'on peut avec cette
mesure dans les six mois à venir faire
en tribe un peu plus de cent mille
jeunes dans les tpe
l' union non mais je vais vous donner
l'explication concret parce que le
président est allé au delà de mes
espérances puisque dans mon rapport je
proposais 50000 jeu chiffrait la mesure
à 45 millions d'euros
la décision du président est de doubler
la mesure non seulement il reprend la
mesure mais la double et dans les 430
millions du sommet du 18 janvier il ya
plus de 100 millions d'euros qui sont
prévus pour la cette mesure est donc la
prévision c'est de ne pas faire
cinquante mille contrats mais d'en faire
cent mille voilà la dure pour pourquoi
la différence parce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que cette mesure est la
capitale pourquoi parce qu'elle est déjà
en place il faut que les chefs
d'entreprises des tpe les jeunes sachent
que dès maintenant cette en place moins
de 26 ans dans les tpe de moins de 10
salariés
c'est un contrat sans charge sans
obligation particulière dans le cadre
d'un contrat très simple il faut rêver
que ce ne sont pas forcément des cdi ça
peut être décédé et très courts cdd de 6
mois minimum
oui ça reste du travail précaire ça
reste ça reste du travail précaire mais
on sait aujourd'hui que dans 70 % des
cas
un jeune qui passent six mois dans une
entreprise ont 70% des cas deux ou trois
mois plus tard on le retrouve dans un
emploi pérenne c'est pour ça que je suis
pas d'accord du tout avec la mesure 2
de françois hollande de créer 150 mille
emplois dans l'est dans les services
publics parce que l'étude de la dares et
éclaire et personne ne la conteste
un jeune qui passent six mois dans le
service public 70% du temps après on le
retrouve à nouveau au chômage dans les
entreprises celle inverse le travail
pour les jeunes demain c'est dans les
entreprises c'est dans le secteur
marchand et c'est pas dans les services
plainte
cette mesure des mises en place que pour
six mois c'est d'ailleurs le temps de la
campagne six mois vous regrettez qu'elle
ne s'applique que sur ces mois
maintenant les jeunes les jeunes qui
vont ces mesures conjoncturelles si
formidable c'est une mesure mais
d'ailleurs je crois que la porte a été
ouverte et xavier bertrand l'a dit
récemment je crois que d'ailleurs je
vais rendre une fois de plus hommage à
son travail
d'ailleurs il va mobiliser les gens dès
la semaine prochaine sur toute la france
et cette mesure si elle a le succès que
j'espère pourra d'ailleurs être
prolongée au delà de la période de six
mois ça a été clairement clairement dit
devant les partenaires sociaux
mais vous voyez bien que face à ce
problème d'urgence du chômage il est
comme important que quelqu'un reste aux
commandes et qu'on n'est pas que des
candidats dans notre pays mais que
jusqu'au bout en face notre travail à la
présidence n'est absolument pas à la
hauteur des besoins sur le chômage des
jeunes est ce que vous voyez ce que ce
que la gauche propose pour nos tours nos
jeunes le programme du parti socialiste
c'était trois cent mille jeunes dans les
services publics monsieur hollande a
carrément coupé en deux il en prend plus
que 150000 la feuille de route que j'ai
proposé il n'y a pas que les salles et
100000 dans les tpe
il ya le passage de six cent mille à 900
mille le nombre des alternants contrat
de professionnalisation et contrat
d'apprentissage la feuille de route que
j'ai proposé pour le quinquennat à venir
ces 350 mille emplois de plus pour les
jeunes dans le secteur marchand dans les
entreprises non je vais gérer mais qu'on
parle un petit peu des seniors aussi
clermont chômage a explosé cette année
chez les seniors en 2011
est ce que c'est une bonne formule de
reculer l'âge de la retraite alors
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas dans notre
société
que faire des seniors dans les
entreprises dans tous les pays où l'on a
avancé le
l'âge du départ à la retraite c'est là
où le chômage des jeunes explose
l'idée qui consiste à dire on va envoyer
les gens à la retraite beaucoup plus tôt
parce que ça fera de la place aux jeunes
ça a été testé dans tous les pays
européens
partout oui comment les conserver le
plus longtemps dans l'entreprise
comment conserver les seniors le plan
aujourd'hui le chômage et c'est ce que
je trouve très facilement je ne vous a
pas échappé comme qu'on a fait la
réforme des retraites et que
mécaniquement çà c'est qu'on en parle
assez peu mais mécaniquement la réforme
des retraites maintient les seniors dans
l'entreprise plus longtemps pourquoi ce
chômage des seniors at il exposé la
coutellerie un atelier dire que le
chômage a augmenté en france c'est une
évidence ce qu'on dit simplement c'est
qu'il a beaucoup moins explosé en france
qu'ailleurs je crois que valérie
rosso-debord l'a dit tout à l'heure les
statistiques sont là et il ya urgence
pour faire en sorte qu'ils n'explosent
pas c'est ça les mesures du 18 janvier
et c'est ça aussi que le président a
posé la mesure sur l'emploi des seniors
dans l'entreprise l'emploi des seniors
aujourd'hui explose l'emploi des seniors
dans l'entreprise c'est la mesure
générale qu'il faut prendre de baisse du
coût du travail quelle mesure est bien
le président de la cub va s'exprimer
je pense que c'est pas moi qui vais vous
dire ce que va dire le président invité
avant lui
je pense que le coût du travail qui est
quand même de 20% plus important en
france qu'en allemagne par exemple
ce coût du travail je pense que c'est la
clé du problème c'est une mesure qui est
une mesure transversale et qui
permettrait si on arrivait à faire
baisser le coût du travail à la fois de
faire entrer beaucoup plus tu es jeune
et de maintenir les seniors c'est une
mesure qui sait rien en tout cas demande
aujourd'hui aux sessions spécifiques
donc sur l'emploi des seniors dans mon
rapport en tout cas pas parce que je
vous parle en général est en général un
projet qui sera bientôt dévoilé écoutez
moi je
il faudrait pas non mais je vais vous
dire ce que je pense fondamentalement
sur ce sujet je suis plus à l'âge des
seniors ça vous a pas échappé
je pense quand même que le problème
majeur pour l'avenir de notre société
qui touche toutes les familles c'est
quand même
l'emploi des jeunes
une société comme la france qui les 650
mille jeunes chômage ne peut pas
préparer son avenir et non seulement ça
trouble la jeunesse et notre pays mais
c'est un trouble aussi les familles
leurs parents leurs devoirs tir du
moment à partir du moment où on demande
aux français de travailler plus tard il
faut que les entreprises intègrent
l'idée qu'elle doit faire travailler
leurs seniors et n'est pas forcément
j'ai un succès qui sont plus chers on
sait qu'ils sont voilà pas formation et
estime qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que le maintien des seniors plus
longtemps dans l'entreprise grâce à la
réforme des retraites notamment fait en
sorte que le poids le poids global sur
l'économie de nos déficits publics étant
moins élevé du coup ça favorise l'emploi
des jeunes dans tous les pays où l'âge
de la retraite est le plus lointain il y
a moins de chômage des jeunes l'idée que
l'on fait partir les anciens pour faire
de la place aux jeunes c'est pas bon et
donc c'est pour ça que il n'y a pas de
mesures spécifiques pour pour l'emploi
des seniors parce que les mesures qui
vont être prises structurel est annoncée
par le président éric normalement elles
doivent favoriser l'emploi de tout le
monde est dans l'urgence et ce qu'il
faut surtout c'est éviter l'explosion du
chômage
très bien on passe maintenant au service
minimum dans le transport aérien
la majorité l'a appelé de ses voeux
depuis la grève de décembre dernier les
députés ont adopté la proposition de loi
sur ce service garanti les salariés
devront désormais sous peine de
sanctions se déclarer 48 heures avant
chaque jour de grève avant nous nous
souhaitons parce que nous sommes
favorables à la négociation
nous souhaitons retirer ce délai de 48
heures j'attire votre attention quand
même sur les conditions très
restrictives dans lesquelles le conseil
constitutionnel l'avait acceptée et qui
ne me semble pas ici ni sur le champ ni
sur les conditions garantie dans un
grand quotidien je dis très clairement
si 100% des pilotes sont en grève y aura
100 % des avions qui ne décolleront pas
simplement ça permettra deux jours à
l'avance de le dire au passage et voilà
c'est qui est bien la preuve que le
droit de grève et 46 mais ce qui est
bien aussi la preuve qu'ils aient un
minimum d'informations ce que vous
refusez pour les passagers
alors cette mesure existe dans le
transporter est depuis 2007 il était
temps d'y ajouter l'aérien oui je crois
il faut être cohérent
j'ai bien compris que le candidat
socialiste avait dit qu'il ne remettrait
pas en question la loi sur le service
minimum je note que les socialistes et
toute la gauche a voté contre
et c'est vraiment a voté contre avec
beaucoup beaucoup de protestations
aujourd'hui monsieur hollande nous dit
qu'il remettra pas en cause cette fois
il a même dit qu'elle marche aujourd'hui
quand il ya des grèves
les français peuvent se déplacer au sol
c'est pas encore le cas dans les airs et
donc l'idée c'est de faire en sorte que
pour le transport aérien aussi 48 heures
de préavis c'est quand même un minimum
de pour que les français soient pas
piéger comme ça en arrivant à l'aéroport
la gauche toujours contre je parie que
lorsque ce texte sera en place ils ne
remettront pas en cause non plus à les
repasser au jeudi
vous allez être contents parce qu'on va
parler des engagements du candidat
hollande il y en a 60
c'est un timing bien réglée après le
show à l'américaine du bourget place au
détail des mesures en ce jeudi devant
400 journalistes françois hollande
égrène ses 60 propositions côté dépenses
20 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
côté recettes entre autres le pactole de
la baisse des niches fiscales baisse qui
rapporterait 29 milliards le sujet de
sandra cerqueira en plein coeur du 11e
arrondissement de paris c'est la cohue
des grands jours devant la maison des
métallos au lieu du syndicalisme
parisien et le lieu n'a pas été choisi
au hasard c'est la mémoire nous
françois hollande vient détailler ses 60
engagement pour la france un projet à la
première personne
face aux 400 journalistes présents fini
le lyrisme le ton n'est pas le même
qu'au bourget plus professoral un défilé
de chiffres de pourcentage de milliards
presque un cours de rigueur mon projet
repose sur quatre principes
le premier c'est la lucidité sur la
gravité de la situation
l'ampleur de la crise et l'état du pays
je ne promets que ce que je suis capable
de tenir pas moins pas plus qu'à roland
de se présenter en candidat crédible et
raisonnable ce discours c'est aussi
l'occasion de riposter à la droite qui
l'accusent de vouloir piétiner les
classes moyennes mais là encore jamais
le nom de nicolas sarkozy n'est cité au
détour d'une phrase françois hollande
s'autorise même à parler au futur comme
s'ils se voyaient déjà à l'elysée
je ne veux pas faire ce que nos
prédécesseurs ont hélas se poser comme
règle c'est à dire des prévisions
totalement décalé par rapport à la
réalité au bourget françois hollande a
essayé de convaincre la gauche du ps
aujourd'hui il s'est adressé un
électorat plus large de potentiels
électeurs de l'autre françois françois
bayrou
alors vous avez commencé votre réaction
dans un communiqué de presse je lis il
réalise démagogique contreproductif il
ya rien à sauver dans ce sens ces
propositions écoutez franchement on est
tous vraiment à l' inverse de ce que
note de ce que l'on doit faire pour
l'avenir de notre pays
les déficits publics tout le monde est
d'accord aujourd'hui pour dire qu'il
faut absolument les réduire le programme
de françois hollande c'est une
c'est une addition de déficits publics
supplémentaires compensé par des
recettes fiscales super content
s'équilibre oui compenser compensé par
un matraquage fiscal de 30 milliards on
se demande où il va les prendre et il va
les prendre sur les forces qui
produisent c'est à dire l'entreprise et
les salariés
donc franchement on a l'impression d'un
retour en arrière de 20 ans et tous les
pays qui nous entourent y compris les
pays sociaux démocrates qui ont réussi
ont fait exactement l'inversé
il faut réduire les déficits publics il
faut libérer les énergies
il faut encourager la production faut
baisser le coût du travail pour être
plus compétitif la france et dans le
monde
la mondialisation est là alors on peut
essayer de la réguler un peu mais en
tout cas les règles économiques sont là
on peut pas se plaindre qu'il ya des
chômeurs et proposer des mesures qui
vont augmenter le chômage
j'ai acheté j'attire votre attention
aussi sur le fait que le financement de
ce projet repose sur une croissance en
2015 qui serait de 2,5 ou 2,7 pour cent
donc tout ça me paraît totalement
irréaliste pour l'instant part donc en
deçà des prières les programmes de l'ump
qui avait basé ses prévisions croissance
un petit peu plus haute
on verra quelle sera le le programme du
candidat de la majorité j'ai noté que
pour le programme de françois hollande
n'est plus le programme du parti
socialiste
donc on verra quand notre programme
celui nous soutiendrons c'est à dire
celui du président sortant ce que
j'espère on verra si on verra comment
les choses seront retenues et chiffré
mais en tout cas oui je persiste et je
signe
c'est contre-productif pour l'économie
c'est totalement irréaliste
en ce qui concerne le financement
justement vous parlez de matraquage
fiscal on l'a beaucoup entendu cette
expression en particulier sur les
classes moyennes c'est qu'ils les
classes moyennes on a du mal à quelle
est la fourchette de salaire quelles
sont les mesures qui vont les toucher
ces classes moyennes moi je vais pas
employer le terme de classes moyennes je
vais je vais en salle non mais je vous
dis d'ailleurs je n'ai pas employé vous
avez entendu nous a dit jeudi les forces
productives les forces productives et ce
sont les forces productives et sont dans
l'entreprise que ce soit les chefs
d'entreprise ou leurs collaborateurs les
salariés c'est là qu'on produit les
richesses qui nous permettent de
financer le modèle social on est très
attachés notre modèle social et moi
aussi
et donc il faut il faut absolument
conforter notre financement mais le
financement on peut pas le prendre
éternellement alors qu'on a déjà 20 %
d'écart de productivité avec l'allemagne
peut pas le prendre éternellement sur
les forces qui produise il faut quand
même il faut quand même regarder comment
faire dans l'avenir y compris pour
trouver un autre financement
c'est ce que nous proposons pour notre
modèle social et les propos de monsieur
hollande au delà du fait que c'est vrai
le meeting a été réussi pourquoi ne pas
le dire sur le plan de la communication
sur le plan de l'ambiance
voilà très bien mais le fond des mesures
est ce que est ce qu elles sont
est ce que c'est bon pour notre pays et
là je franchement je suis atterré de
voir que on revient à des mesures d'il
ya 20 ans
un mot sur ce que devrait annoncer
nicolas sarkozy la tva sociale est ce
que c'est normal d'ouvrir des chantiers
aussi important à quelques semaines
d'une présidentielle est ce qu'ils vont
pas mieux attendre pour réformer non
parce que je crois franchement que cinq
ans c'est très très vite passé six mois
en économie aujourd'hui six mois c'est
très rapide
rappelez-vous 2009 la crise financière
personne ne nous l'annoncent n'ya pas un
grand spécialiste qui nous annonce la
crise financière après on nous dit que
c'est fini
quelques mois plus tard ça recommence il
faut être très réactif et des mesures
d'urgence à prendre
le président rend va rendre un grand
service à la france en ouvrant avant les
élections présidentielles se débat en
proposant au parlement de prendre des
décisions y compris si ces décisions
sont prises
après s'ils sont décision qui ce sont
des décisions qui vont dans le sens de
l'intérêt de notre pays
je suis persuadé que personne une fois
de plus personne ne les remettra en
question parce que ce sera l'intérêt
général et on va terminer cette émission
avec une vidéo qui a fait beaucoup
parler et sourire cette semaine c'est le
clip tourné par les jeunes socialistes
avec le fameux signe de ralliement jean
mathis der aulas au coeur du buzz ce
geste de ralliement à françois hollande
pipoles politiques et anonymes mime avec
leurs bras les deux barres horizontales
autour du slogan du candidat
la vidéo est vu plusieurs centaines de
milliers de fois en 24 heures
un succès d'audience mais sur internet
la limite entre bons et mauvais buzz est
souvent étroites les journalistes web
échange des commentaires consterné sur
twitter et l'ump se gausse du clip de
campagne
très vite les parodies se multiplient le
blogueur guy birenbaum voit dans la
vidéo du camp hollande
un hommage à un vieux tube de l'été
à l'assemblée les députés socialistes
assument leur participation même s'ils
n'ont pas forcément tout compris à la
vidéo j'ai pensé que ça faisait
référence au haka des néo-zélandais je
trouve ça mais j'ai vu qu'ils sont soit
très bien alors il dit si je sais pas il
faut demander aux cyclos mj mais ça ça
donne quand même de du dynamisme de la
pêche et de la gaieté alors que la vidéo
est très critiqué sur internet les
sénateurs socialistes se montrent plutôt
téméraire
ils ont posté aujourd'hui leur propre
version du clip bref le collant de fait
front derrière sa vidéo mais le buzz
rappel d'ores et déjà un autre naufrage
bien connu des internautes
le fameux lipdub de l'ump à l'été 2009
marché de l'essence
à l'époque les ministres présents dans
la vidéo avait mis plusieurs mois avoué
publiquement qu'il regrette d'y avoir
participé à la jarrie rendez vous y
aviez participé à ces leaders donc je
trouve sur le principe ça met un peu de
fraîcheur parce que la société est
tellement triste on je trouve qu'on
n'est pas assez optimiste parce que je
moi qui me suis beaucoup occupé des
jeunes tous ces temps ci il ya tellement
de deux d'enthousiastes dans la jeunesse
tellement créativité tellement de
potentiel pour notre société
c'est pas moi qui vais qui avait
critiqué un peu de voix là me choque pas
je pensais un point partout là où
franchement si on me met un peu
d'ambiance aussi et puis et puis
regarder l'avenir avec de temps en temps
un tout petit peu de décontraction de
sérénité s'empêche pas le sérieux
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette
émission
pour finir on adresse bien sûr un salut
à celui qui co présente régulièrement
cette émission mickaël szames s il est
papa d'une petite chiara l'on souhaite
la bienvenue à kara ont fait si on
félicite bien sûr la maman et puis un
tout petit peu de mickels naissent aussi
comme voilà voilà eh bien nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même lieu
même heure bonne cela bien voir ou
revoir